roads blocked and cones on the ground
the aftermath of a crash las vegas is no
stranger to the dangers the roads can
bring a greater percentage of people
will die at the scene and a greater
percentage of people will be seriously
injured dr deborah kuhls is a critical
care surgeon at umc and a lead
investigator with the unlv's kirkokorian
school of medicine to study deaths and
injuries on nevada's roads i get that
sense every day when i'm on trauma call
but to take an overall look and to
actually create data with a nearly 500
thousand dollar grant from the nevada
department of public safety dr cool and
her team take a deep dive into every
single crash i can look for particular
injury patterns let's say among
pedestrians according to the nevada
department of public safety in 2021
there were 289 people who died in our
roads 59 of them were pedestrians the
leading cause is impairment and speeding
you do not have time to stop
if someone is trying to cross the street
they don't have time to see you laura
grider is a project director for this
traffic safety study she says the kova
19 pandemic in 2020 really set the tone
for reckless driving in our area they
were having
very they were experiencing very high
speeds and we were seeing some very
intense and deadly crashes she says as
las vegas expands it becomes less
pedestrian friendly with wider roads